So Martin suggests using an alternative approach to OOA is to
write out use cases.
Recall that a use case is a simple story illustrating a single execution or
pointing out an important obstacle that the user might confront.
For the case of the coffeemaker can you come up with a few use cases?
What's brewin'?
>> So if they did press the brew button, but that was,
I guess, the first use case there's a couple of things that could happen.
Everything could be right, because all of our pre-conditions are there,
or there could be no water for the brewing process to start, or
just the filter's not in place, or no coffee grounds.
Those are some problems that could happen.
>> So on, on that one notice that so far we haven't, we don't have an sensor for
the grounds.
OK. So if there's no grounds in there you're going to get very,
very weak coffee.
>> Okay.
>> And if there's no filter, you're going to get your coffee pretty quickly.
>> Right.
I guess I have a question that regards to that use case.
Is the problem of them not having coffee grounds something that
the system should even worry about?
Because it seems like that would be hard to tell, like the filter being in
place I can imagine being something a sensor could tell.
But how much coffee is in your, your filter could be,
maybe something that's not supported, I don't know.
>> So this is an issue with designing software and hardware at the same time.
So you could imagine, for example in the Mark 5 having a sensor for
the recep, receptacle actually clicking in.
Okay.
When you, when you push it in there.
Trying to figure out how many grounds are in there or how, you know, how deep
the grounds are or something our hardware people haven't gotten that one yet.
Okay, so we're, we're not going to be able to sense that very well.
>> It sounds a little bit like trying to
count jelly beans in a jar or something.
But anyways the other use cases I have involve remember moving or
placing the pot because we have an indicator for that.
>> Right, right. >> So it's something that stood out.
And then also when you fill the water receptacle.
We have an indicator whether the water is there or not.
So that seemed to be a, an interaction that had something the user could see.
>> So let's consider four of those.
The user press, press pushes the brew button, and that's our primary one.
And then some contingent ones containment vessel is not ready.
The coffee is all gone or
we could have that the, the brewing is actually complete.